do J's responses in very short order
it's my hope so I thank you for that
it's my hope that under your leadership
the department will continue to respond
expeditiously to this year's questions
for the records and one of the things I
remember from the conversation we had
before your confirmation was your
commitment to work closely with Congress
and the subcommittee in particular to
have an open dialogue and a transparent
conversation and your answer to those
questions on the record will be and
continue to be appreciated I would add
an additional thank you which is thank
you for your presence here today this
testimony is important and I now
recognize the ranking member senator
Shaheen well Thank You mr. chairman
good morning Attorney General bar thank
you for appearing before this
subcommittee I share the Chairman's view
that we want to try and focus mostly on
your budget but I have to begin with two
concerns that I have about actions that
you and the Justice Department have
taken first I saw your testimony
yesterday and I still do have questions
on the special counsels report as I
believe this report has serious national
security implications we know that
Russia interfered in our election we
know that the special counsel has
brought nearly 200 charges against 34
individuals and three companies
including six former Trump officials and
26 Russian nationals I am concerned by
recent media reports that those working
on the special counsels team believe
your summary to Congress glossed over
the severity of the damaging actions of
those in the White House including the
president the American people should be
allowed to see the report in its
entirety so they can make their own
judgments about its content I am also
troubled by the department's recent
decision to support a district court
decision that would completely
invalidate the Affordable Care Act I
have questions for you as to why this
decision was made this recent action by
the Department will put millions of
Americans including 118 thousand Granite
Staters at risk of being unable to
afford or simply not have access to
their current health care coverage the
loss of protections for pre-existing
conditions and soar in particular
prescription drug costs for seniors will
affect thousands and this includes
vulnerable Americans like a young boy
named Seth from Northfield New Hampshire
he lives with hemophilia it's a disease
that requires hundreds of thousands of
dollars of medication and treatment
costs every month before the Affordable
Care Act Seth's father would have to
change jobs because Seth's medical costs
were constantly running up against the
family's annual limits on the dollar
value of insurance coverage children
like Seth those living with pre-existing
conditions stand to lose the most if the
Affordable Care Act is wiped out they
could be denied insurance coverage
because of their medical condition and
insurers would be able to jack up costs
and cut off coverage after medical bills
reach an arbitrary threshold I believe
we need to work together Republicans and
Democrats to improve improve the health
care law not unravel it and I hope that
we will be able to do that in the coming
months and years I do acknowledge as I
said that you were here today in your
role as Attorney General to explain the
department's fiscal year 20 budget
request the complex and often difficult
work of the department is vast ranging
from national security investigations to
operating a national prison system to
management of billions in grants to
state and local entities yet in fiscal
year 2020 the department has requested
nearly 2 percent less funding for its
missions than the level provided in the
omnibus we passed last month the Bureau
of Prisons is a large part of this
reduction a cut of 188 million below
what we just enacted in fiscal year
nineteen it's disconcerting that the
department would slash the budget for Bo
P in light of our direction in Congress
to continue hiring particularly so as
not to rely on augmentation which is the
dangerous practice of using
administrative staff like teachers and
counselors as correctional officers
including expanding programming for
inmates cutting programming for inmates
and facilities across the country
including at FCI berlin in my home state
of new hampshire it's also troubling
that the department seems to have
forgotten about meeting the requirements
for prisoner re-entry as part of the
recently passed first step act there's
only 14 million requested with little
detail as to how you plan to use that
money when 75 million has been
authorized for this effort I was also
surprised about drastic reductions and
eliminations proposed for Justice
Department grant programs including
those to help our communities fight
opioids
I am deeply concerned that this budget
request cuts nearly 100 million in
funding that we just provided for
Justice grant programs to help
communities respond to the opioid crisis
with a balance of enforcement treatment
and prevention programs I'm interested
to hear your reasons why your FY 20 but
dramatically reduces this critical
funding and even eliminates key programs
like cops
Anto anti-heroin task forces which we
provided 32 million to cover and
mentoring programs for youth who are
directly affected by the toll opioids
have had on their families and
communities we funded that at 15 million
we see this very dramatically in New
Hampshire where as I think we discussed
previously we have the third highest
overdose death rate in the country I
understand that there's more demand on
these programs than even we have in
Congress have appropriated so what I
don't understand is why we're talking
about eliminating them in closing I want
to echo the appreciation that was
expressed by chairman Moran for the 112
career employees at the Department of
Justice they worked very hard to keep
Americans safe from crime and terrorism
and especially during the government
shutdown they worked without any
guarantee that they would be paid so I
know that I speak for everybody on this
many and thanking them for their service
I look forward to your testimony today
mr. Attorney General before we turn to
the Attorney General for his remarks I'd
recognize the vice chairman of the full
committee Senator Leahy for any comments
an opening statement he'd like to make I
agree with both you and senator Shaheen
and the 112,000 who kept on working
during the shutdown went on for 35 days
I remember very well the day it ended
when four of us met in my office under
Shelby myself
congresswoman Lowey and congresswoman
Granger and we made an agreement on the
on the Appropriations and fortunately
Republicans the Democrats joined with us
on in past the president vetoed the
first one because they had him only 1.6
billion for the wall the agreement that
we agreed to gave 1.3 billion but he
accepted that and I thought it's about
time we got back to work now there are a
lot of pressing issues facing Justice
Department immigration enforcement
combating opioids violent crime
protecting voting rights and a lot of
these are going to be discussed this
morning there'll be another oversight
hearings I first want to express my
appreciation to Robert Moeller and his
team for their service to our country
they determine exactly what happened
during unprecedented attack on her
democracy we already know from their
investigations 37 indictments they can
uncovered serious misconduct reaching
some of the highest level even if the
president's involvement did not amount
to approvable crime and thankfully so
the American people and the
representatives in Congress don't expect
to see the special counsels work
that's my hope that you're still
committed to the greatest possible
degree of transparency as you know
classified material
can be shared with Congress and and is
on a constant basis there but there's
also precedence for sharing grand jury
information as well especially in
high-profile investigations at Keene
Public Interest an ongoing
investigations another reason to redact
certain information like all things in
life eventually end one way or another
the vast majority of the special
counsels report will ultimately become
public I think attempts to hide swaths
of the report from public scrutiny along
the way will only fuel suspicions have
been raised by many that the Justice
Department which represents United
States is playing the role of president
from defense team for the integrity of
the department I know you well enough to
know that you agree this as a result
that must be avoided your imprint on the
course of justice and rule of law in
these moments are gonna be scrutinized
long after both you and I are gone from
public service the only way out in my
view is transparency you do have the
discretion to release the full report to
Congress nothing in the level of the law
stands in your way so I open the coming
weeks you work in good faith the
Congress to accomplish that and mr.
Chairman I will have a number of
questions on me on the budget and I
appreciate the courtesy being recognized
you're welcome mr. vice chairman
attorney general bar we're ready for
your testimony thank you for joining us
and anxious to hear what you have to say
Thank You chairman Moran Thank You
chairman Moran and ranking member
Shaheen and vice-chair Leahy and members
of the subcommittee I'm pleased to be
here today to present the president's
fiscal year 2020 budget for the
Department of Justice I'm joined here
today by the department's chief
financial officer Assistant Attorney
General for administration Leigh Loftus
we're looking forward to discussing how
our requested appropriations will help
protect the safety and the rights of
your constituents rather than read a
statement to you let me just say that
I'm here to talk about the department's
twenty nine point two billion dollar FY
20 but request I believe the budget
request supports our priorities we're
seeking a hundred and twenty eight
million to income increases for our
violent crime prevention work we're
seeking 291 million enhancements for our
drug abuse and opioid efforts we have a
hundred and thirty one million for our
national security and cybercrime efforts
and I'm seeking an additional 72 million
for our immigration work I'm proud of
the department's accomplishments and our
workforce of more than one hundred and
twelve thousand men and women and I'm
looking forward to your support for the
resources we need for their important
work with that I'm happy to answer any
questions
attorney general thank you for your
brief statement and thanks for the
opportunity to ask you questions I would
just reiterate and ask for an answer to
the question I raised in my opening
statement I was uncertain as to what you
were conveying yesterday during your
house testimony about whether you will
provide a report of the report or a
redacted version of the mowers actual
mower report yes it's my intention to
provide the latter as I said in my
confirmation hearing you know the the
regulation under which we're operating
did not contemplate and specifically was
meant to avoid these public reports but
I feel I have the discretion in these
circumstances to make the report public
as long as it's consistent with law and
as I said at my hearing that I was going
to try to be as transparent as possible
and that's what I've been working toward
there are four areas
I intend to release the report with
redactions made in four areas and they
specified in my March 29th letter the
first area is 6e material because and
I'm talking here by the way about the
public a report that would be available
to the public generally and then I'll
talk a little bit about the report
available to Committees of Congress the
report I'm working on now I would like
to make available with redactions that
would enable me to make it public
generally and there are four categories
the Grand Jury material which my law
must be retained within the department
absent very specific circumstances which
I do not think exists here second
category is any material identified by
the intelligence community that would
put at risk intelligence sources and
methods the third category is
information that would impair existing
prosecution's and investigations that
are going forward right now either by
affecting the ability of the department
to pursue them as effectively as we'd
like or being unfair the individuals who
are actually parties to that prosecution
you will recognize that Special Counsel
Muller did spin off a number of cases
which continued in progress and are
being handled in the department and so
we have to make sure that nothing in the
report impinges on those ongoing cases
and the final category is information
that implicates the privacy or
reputational interests of peripheral
third parties who are not charged now
the people who are making these
redactions and and implementing these
four categories are the department
working with the Special Counsel office
lawyers and those are the people
involved in making the redactions so as
I mentioned yesterday we plan to
identify very specifically which
redactions relate to which category and
try to explain why that redaction was
made I also said yesterday
when it comes to Congress once I get
this done the public everyone has the
report I'm willing to work with the
committee's the regulation requires that
doesn't acquire but it but it has my
notification go to the Judiciary
Committees and I intend to take up with
the house and the Senate Judiciary
Committee's a chair and the ranking
members of each what other areas you
know they feel they have a need to have
access to the information and see if I
can work to accommodate that as has been
correctly said here the fact that
information is classified does not
necessarily mean that Congress can't see
it so I'm willing to work on some of
these categories the category I think is
the most inflexible under the law right
now is the is the grand jury material
but even there once the redactions are
completed I intend to read the report
and see if they're areas where it
affects the intelligibility or really
has an impact report and I'm willing to
work with the Judiciary Committee's to
see if there's a workaround that could
address any concerns or needs that they
have general under the assumption that
your answer was of interest to my
colleagues I'm going to continue with
another question beyond my my time I
want to talk about grant funding that's
been delayed due to litigation
surrounding sanctuary cities mm-hmm
so in the past the department has tried
to enforce federal immigration law by
imposing special conditions or bonus
points on recipients of federal grant
funding these conditions restrict grant
funding to jurisdictions that certify
they're in compliance with federal law
stating that they are not sanctuary
cities or states that's not something
that I'm complaining about in this
question what I'm concerned about is the
money that has been held up as a result
of that litigation because of the
pending litigation in regard to burn jag
grant funds we've had success
in that occurring but unfortunately that
has not been the case in the FY 18 cops
hiring grants these solicitations were
pulled and applicants are still unable
to apply for cops hiring grants going
back to FY 18 Awards have you reviewed
the department's policies is there a
plan to figure out how that we can can
provide those necessary resources to
local law enforcement to retain and hire
law enforcement officers yes I think
this is a the problem is really a
function of this phenomenon of
nationwide injunctions that imposed by
district court judges and this is
actually a fairly recent phenomenon the
old the old practice and law was that if
a district court judge issued a decision
the judge could redress the grievances
of the parties before the court but now
courts are granting nationwide
injunctions as a result if a district
court in north Northern California which
is I think the court that may have been
involved here grants an injunction they
enjoin the grant program nationwide now
one of the reasons we were able to and
and leaked and correct me if I'm wrong
about this but one of the reasons we
were able to get out the the Byrne jag
grants was that there had been a
district court in Chicago that had
enjoined it nationwide we went to the
Seventh Circuit they required the court
to reduce its injunction just to its
jurisdiction and and when that happened
we were able to get out the Byrne jag
grants what's happened with the cops
grants is that it's enjoined by a
district several district court judges
we're arguing if not today within the
next few days in the seventh and ninth
circuit to try to have that address so
we can get those those grants out but
frankly I think we need to come to grips
with this issue of nationwide
injunctions because I think the way the
system should do these issue issue
should percolate up through various
circuit courts and so forth up to the
Supreme
Court and the idea that one district
court judge can kill programs nationwide
is a serious problem thank you for your
answer if you're successful in finding a
path to see that the cops grants are
available please be prepared as a
department to proceed quickly wouldn't
that if and when that occurs and I don't
think local law enforcement has been
able to even submit a grant application
so it is significantly delayed and maybe
there's a way that those grant
applications I don't know what the
injunction covers but maybe there's a
way to submit the grant application even
if you can't award a grant until you
receive judicial authority to do so I
look I'll look into that Thank You
senator shaheen Thank You mr. chairman
and let me just echo what senator Moran
was saying about the cops grants
particularly in states like New
Hampshire where we have no sanctuary
cities it's very onerous for us to be
affected by these rulings I want to go
back to your comments about the four
reasons that you intend to redact
portions of the special council's report
the fourth one was information that
would unduly infringe on the personal
privacy and reputational interests of
peripheral third parties what does that
mean that you will redact information to
protect the reputation illiteracy of the
president no I'm talking about people in
private life okay that's not public law
office holders thank you news just broke
today that you have a special team
looking into why the FBI open an
investigation into Russian interference
in the 2016 elections I wonder if you
couldn't share with this committee who's
on that team why you felt a need to form
that kind of a team and what you intend
to be the scope of their investigation
yeah I as I said in my confirmation
hearing I am gonna be reviewing both the
genesis and the conduct of intelligence
activities directed again at the Trump
campaign during 2016 and a lot has
already been invested a lot of this has
already
been investigated in a substantial
portion of it has been investigated and
is being investigated by the Office of
Inspector General at the department but
one of the things I want to do is pull
together all the information from the
various investigations that have gone on
including on the hill and in the
department and see if there are any
remaining questions to be addressed and
can you share with us why you feel a
need to do that well you know for the
same well for the same reason we're
worried about foreign influence and
elections we want to make sure that
during elect I think spying on a
political campaign is a big deal it's a
big deal
generation I grew up in which is the
Vietnam War a period you know people
were all concerned about spying on
anti-war people and so forth
by the government and there were a lot
of rules put in place to make sure that
there's an adequate basis before before
our law enforcement agencies get
involved in politics and opal itical
surveillance I'm not suggesting that
those rules were violated but I think
it's important to look at that and I'm
not just I'm not talking about the FBI
necessarily but intelligence agencies
more broadly so you're not you're not
suggesting though that spine occurred
I guess you could I think there was a
spying did occur yes I think spying did
occur
Wow let me my question is whether it was
predicated adequately predicated and I'm
not suggesting it wasn't adequately
predicated but I need to explore that I
think it's my obligation Congress is
usually very concerned about
intelligence agencies and law
enforcement agencies staying in their
proper Lane and I want to make sure that
happened and I want to say that I've
said I'm reviewing this I am going I
haven't set up a team yet but I do have
I have in mind
having some colleagues help me pull all
this information together and let me
know whether there's some areas that
should be looked at and I also want to
make clear this is not launching an
investigation of the FBI I frankly I'm
to the extent there were there were any
issues at the FBI I do not view it as a
a problem that's endemic to the FBI I
think there was probably a failure among
a group of leaders there at the upper
echelon and so I don't like to hear
attacks about the FBI because I think
the FBI is an outstanding organization
and I think you know Chris Rae is a
great partner for me I'm very pleased
that he's there is the director and if
it becomes necessary to look over some
former officials activities I expect
that I'll be relying heavily on Chris
and and work closely with him and
looking at that information but that's
what I'm doing I feel I have an
obligation to make sure that government
power is not abused I mean I think
that's one of the principal roles of the
Attorney General I certainly agree I
think we all have an obligation to
ensure that government power is not
abused the question I have is what
happens when the executive is
potentially playing that role and that's
where it doesn't seem to me there has
been adequate oversight Thank You mr.
chairman
Souter Collins Thank You mr. chairman
welcome mr. attorney-general last June
your predecessor than Attorney General
Sessions announced that the department
would no longer defend the Affordable
Care Act's
pre-existing conditions provisions
because they were inseparable from the
ACA 'z individual mandate two weeks ago
your department went much further
deciding that it would not defend any
provisions of the ACA this puts at risk
other important provisions in addition
to protection for people with
pre-existing conditions such as the
Medicaid expansion dependent coverage
for young adults up to age 26 and
coverage for preventive services now the
individual mandate is a highly
regressive penalty and I've long to post
it and Congress repealed it but I
disagree strongly with the department's
decision not to defend the rest of the
ACA in a letter that I wrote to your
predecessor last June and to you on
April 1st I made the point that the
individual mandate can be struck down
and severed from the ACA well the
remainder of the law can stay in place
and this isn't just my opinion in 2010
the Chief Justice Roberts said in the
pre Enterprise Fund case that under the
doctrine of severability that generally
speaking when confronting a
constitutional flaw we try to limit the
solution to the problem severing any
problematic portions while leaving the
remainder intact in 1990 when you were
head of the Department's Office of Legal
Counsel under President George Herbert
Walker Bush you authored an opinion
finding the
the president could enforce the
remainder of the statute after an
unconstitutional provision had been
severed I agree wholeheartedly with your
1990 opinion what led you to take a
different approach Thank You senator wen
when I visited with you before my
confirmation I promised you that I would
personally take a look at this issue and
I did and I studied it carefully and I
provided my views robustly within the
deliberative process that was going on
within the executive branch as I said
when the Attorney General is providing
legal advice I think the first
obligation is to provide the advice that
you think is the right legal answer and
how you would decide the case if you
were a judge which is what was the
advice I gave but I also have said that
if the other if the other stakeholders
in the executive branch and the people
involved the agencies and so forth end
up in a different place as litigator for
the United States it's it's Attorney
General should be able to advance
positions that he believes are
defensible and reasonable legal
positions even if they are not positions
that the Attorney General would adopt if
the Attorney General was a judge
deciding the case in this situation the
ultimate decision was to support the
position of the states including Texas
and the decision of the district court
judge the rationale for that is that it
is a defensible and reasonable legal
position given that that was the
decision of the district court and the
position of four justices on the
original NFIB case who felt that
when if the mandate goes the rest of the
statute goes I know there's an
additional point there which is the fact
that Congress did take out the penalty
from the from the mandate and therefore
should that act be viewed as essentially
validating the rest of the statute and
those issues were debated but at the end
of the day I felt that the position was
a defensible position and it was the
decision of the executive branch I would
just make the final point that Congress
had the opportunity to strike other
provisions and chose not to yes
Thank You mr. chairman thank you senator
Collins senator leahy Thank You mr.
chairman during general thank you for
being here we over the decades we've had
a chance to talk at these hearings many
times I let me go back to the discussion
of your March 24th letter and you said
the president did not commit obstruction
of justice he said that before any
reference to Congress of course you have
the position that no matter the evidence
you don't believe a president can be
indicted while in office you said the
mechanism has been to ballot or or
Congress not a criminal court did you
have any conversation with the special
counsel about why he did not reach a
conclusion one way or the other on
obstruction yes I did and he also has a
fuller explanation of that in the in the
report that I'll be making available
hopefully next week did he express any
expectation or an interest in leaving
the obstruction decision to Congress
not that he didn't say that to me now so
he said the obstruction decision should
be up to you he didn't say that either
but that's generally how the Department
of Justice works generally grand juries
are to investigate crimes and a
prosecutor's role at the end of the day
is binary are there charges or no
charges or is this a crime or not a
crime
I've had some experience I know I would
agree with me but let me say that I
don't feel you know I'm looking forward
to explaining my decision that that I
briefly outlined in the March 24th
letter but I don't feel I can do it
until the report is out because I think
it's because I think the report contains
a lot of the information that would give
meaning and content to the discussion
and I really can't do it in the absence
of getting it out so I'm anxious to get
it out that's what I've been working
toward and let me I said I come up to
the hill as soon as the hill will have
me which I guess is at the end of the
month to testify about that Moran Aston
and determine what should be redacted
have you overruled mr. Muller or his
team on any redaction question
No one way or the other no have you
discussed any specific redactions with
the White House no just curious before
this came out you were at a sort of an
annual st. Patrick's Day then at the
White House was the t-shirt the prime
minister of Ireland exchanging shamrocks
and so on your long discussion and
parented very you both seem very happy
to discussion you and the president were
you discussing the report was I yeah no
it was actually in front of several
justices of the Supreme Court and other
dignitaries I wasn't alone with the
president
you sure that what so anybody anybody
thinking they heard you say anything
else would be wrong right
you've indicated you redact grand jury
material but of course in both the
Watergate in the Ken Starr
investigations by injury secrecy was
overcome to allow congressional access
have you asked the district court to
release grand jury material to Congress
did you say were you citing the star
investigation and the Watergate yes okay
well the star star investigation
involved this specific statute that rule
6 e 16 brother no no the the star the
statute setting up the Independent
Counsel provided for the report going to
Congress and overrode 60 so I don't be
the storm situations why have you more
specifically if you ask the district
court to release grand jury material no
the law right now is in the District of
Columbia that the court can only waive 6
e for one of the grounds specified
specifically in 6 e there's no sort of
inherent power in the court to do that
and if someone shows me and and and you
know I think makes a persuasive argument
that it's covered I'm willing to listen
to that but I don't see it
and lastly in a dollar amount your
budget I told from ATF would resolved in
300 could lose 370 positions under the
President's budget even though it shows
a slightly increased because of
attrition everything else are you
satisfied with ATF at a time of violent
crime everything out losing these
positions are you talking about the 377
positions that mr. Brandon mentioned I
heard
I understood 370 but okay whichever yeah
we don't think he will lose those
positions there's some complicated
accounting here that I'm sort of a
little mystified by myself but as I
understand and we've been continually
investing and increasing the number of
ATF agents and they were worried about
bringing on too many agents in excess of
funds that were going to be appropriated
and they had sort of the way they
quickly make up for that is to just take
out headcount rather than make cuts
across the board we don't think that
they are and I and and mr. Loftus here
can give you more of an explanation if
you'd want one but let me just say my
time yeah but I really would like more
because you either do his 370 or the
administration's 46 either way it looks
very much like cuts in ATF I can add
senator just say that ATF does have a
four percent increase in this budget and
I have spoken with the ATF chief I think
he's a outstanding guy and worked
closely with him over many years and I
do know that they are concerned about
the resources in their budget but we
have looked at the 4% increase we don't
think the 4% increase translates into a
loss of hundreds of positions but we're
willing to work very closely with ATF
and make sure that we can protect their
certainly their agents and again any
money that ATF receives I think can be
put to very good use and we look forward
to working with both ATF and the
Committee on this on this one sir lady
thank you we have four three votes
scheduled at 11:45 my intention is to go
until those votes are called and don't
anticipate coming back after that occurs
senator Kennedy is recognized Thank You
mr. chairman general I don't intend to
talk much about your budget I think we
both know that Congress will make sure
that you're out of clean fun did that I
want to talk a little bit about the
Muller report I think it was inevitable
that some people were going to be
disappointed in the result of
results that mr. mr. mother reached you
can all wait you can only be young once
you can always be immature there will be
some who were so disappointed in the
result that they're going to attack the
process in bad faith I would strongly
encourage you to eager to ignore that
just call them like you see them follow
them off if you it can we agree that if
you turned over the mother report
without grand jury material redacted to
only members of Congress can we agree
that there is a material risk that the
grand jury information would leak I
think so I mean that's been known to
happen yes occasionally yes in a
sinister - why would that be bad well
because we depend on the secrecy of the
grand jury for our whole system of
justice and people have to be assured
when they go into the grand jury that
they that these are going to be
confidential sessions I got it
can we agree that if you turned over an
unredacted report for the members of the
United States Congress that in included
material that might impair an existing
investigation or investigations that
there's a material risk that that
information might leak yes why is that
bad well it presumably the reason people
are interested in and seeing the report
is because they believe it's important
for the criminal justice process to work
yes sir allowing this other information
to come out would frustrate from the
prosecutors standpoint the system from
working in other cases and from the
defendants standpoint would be unfair
potentially unfair to the defendant
let's talk about reputational risk if
you turn over a report excuse me senator
could I just add something certainly in
some of these cases there are gag orders
from the court prohibiting this
information from
going out okay if you returned a
turnover an unredacted report containing
unredacted information that couldn't
could raise reputational risk can we
agree there's a material risk that that
would leak yes senator why is that bad
well it goes back to the if someone has
not committed a crime at the end of the
day and in this context if they're not
public office holders other private
citizens they the government is not in a
position to say they did anything wrong
it would be unfair from just
fundamentally unfair to put that
information out would that be especially
the case if someone thought their
communication was confidential yes kind
of like dr. Ford
who thought she was making a
confidential communication until some
member of the Judiciary Committee
committee or their staffs turned her
life upside down a week that I'm not
aware of the circumstances myself I'm
not either I wish I were it was probably
the greatest injustice I've seen in the
time I've been here
let me talk a little bit in the minute I
have left and I'm gonna land this plane
on time mr. chairman I know you're
taking a look at the genesis of the
investigations with respect to 2016
election just quickly can we agree that
the FBI is the premier and law
enforcement agency in all of human
history
absolutely and can we agree that we want
FBI agents and Justice Department
members to have thought about the world
thought about socio-economic problems
and thought about how to solve those
problems you don't want a dummy working
for the FBI or the Justice Department
but they're not supposed to act on those
political beliefs are they no senator it
appears to me I'm not gonna ask you this
question there were a handful of men and
women at the FBI possibly at the
Portland Justice who did act on their
political beliefs in 2016
some of them were for Donald Trump you
don't believe me ask Secretary Clinton
some of them were for Secretary Clinton
you don't believe me ask President Trump
and that's not right and we need to stop
this from ever happening again my plane
is landed Thank You senator Kennedy
Senator Reid well thank you very much
mr. chairman Thank You Attorney General
let me return to your March 24th letter
to the Judiciary Committee and along the
lines of Senator Leahy you quote the
special prosecutor excuse me the
director Muller with respect to
allegations of a structure of justice
and you say while
report does not conclude that the
president committed a crime it also does
not exonerate him which raises a
question in my mind did the Special
Counsel client probable cause that a
crime had been committed I'm not gonna
characterize his report the report will
speak for itself and that's why I want
to get it out well then let me just
follow up but but I think my letter says
that he did not find a crime was
committed no I understand that but it's
I think important to note that he you
took his language said I got I did not
find a crime but I can't exonerate the
president that suggests that there's a
possibility that probable cause existed
for a crime however someone either
directly mullah or yourself made a
determination that the evidence would
not be beyond could not convince a jury
beyond a reasonable doubt or that the
policy the department was not to charge
the president because of the
constitutional issue of impeachment so
this is a again I'm trying to understand
why not only director Muller said this
but you repeated it that the president
was not exonerated from the obstruction
of judge's allegations as I explained
yesterday I was trying to state just the
bottom-line conclusions and not
characterize it or try to summarize the
report beyond just stating its
bottom-line conclusions and I thought
the best way of doing that was taking
that language from Bob's Muller's
reported let me sort of turn the
questioner on if there was no evidence
probable cause then I would presume he
could have said very clearly that there
was no crime committed that he could in
fact exonerate the president as he seems
to have done with the allegations of
conspiracy between the campaign and
Russia I think that sentence says he
didn't find he's not it was a crime and
he's not exonerating III which puts and
try to characterize his reasoning
or or his rapport that's why it's
important to get the whole report out
instead of trying to read these little
team I have a bubble cause is a very low
standard for determining when you start
investigating something find a lot of
things have probable cause I understand
that but I think it's important I agree
with your complete it's important get
the whole report out to the American
public because there are serious
questions that we just going back and
forth on and your response I think is
very critical
it's those questions on Capri resolved
until the American people see this
report not sections of it not
paraphrases of it but this entire report
let me just quickly ask for another
question which is do you have any
specific evidence that there was
anything improper in the
counterintelligence investigation by the
FBI or anything improper in the way the
advice was carried out by the special
counsel with respect to the 2016
election do you have any evidence I'm
sorry it was a compound question
compound question there was a
counterintelligence investigation by the
FBI with respect to the 2016 election
involving primarily the Trump campaign
there was an investigation by director
Muller into the 2016 campaign and other
issues have you any evidence that there
was anything improper in those
investigations I've no evidence that I
would sorry right now I do have
questions about it so this panel you're
putting it together and putting together
a panel so you just have some interest
in this you don't have any of those I
have concerns about various aspects of
it do you believe that the investigation
that director Muller undertook was a
witch-hunt or illegal as been asserted
by the President as I said during my
confirmation it really depends on where
you're sitting if you are somebody who
is being falsely accused of something
you would tend to view the investigation
and you're sitting as the Attorney
General of the United States with the
constitutional responsibility so if you
could answer in that regard I might even
characterize the
is what it is mother and his team
conducted an investigation and every
shilling a report I'll use my own
adjectives you can use your own
adjectives and those I don't assume
include witch-hunt or or illegal is that
correct
those would not be in your answer I
haven't referred to the room thank you
very much thank you sir Murkowski Thank
You mr. chairman attorney general
welcome I want to start my questions
with the issue of marijuana
senator Gardner has really taken the
lead on this issue over here in the
Senate I have been supportive of his
efforts he's trying to move forward with
the states act I'm co-sponsoring that
but when we visited and during your
confirmation process you explained that
you believe that the current conflict
between federal and state marijuana laws
is untenable was was the words that you
described you also explained that you
will not upset settled expectation or
the reliance interests that have
developed because of the policies from
the prior administration but you did
state that you believe the current
situation really has to be addressed i I
know and understand that you don't
support the wholesale legalization of
marijuana you made it clear that we face
a binary choice between the federal
prohibition and a quote federal approach
to correct the disconnect between
federal and state marijuana laws and so
I think you you committed to me or and
and to others that this is something
that Congress has to address the right
way which is through legislation and and
we would agree with that I think we
think that the states Act is is an
approach that does what you have
recommended it adjusts the federal law
the right way to create a federal
approach to marijuana I think the
president has expressed some support for
it so can you
share with me share with the committee
where you are on on this approach that
has been outlined in this states act and
whether or not we can we can work with
you on this issue yes senator the
situation that I think is intolerable in
which I'm opposed to is the current
situation where an and I would prefer
one of two approaches rather than where
we are personally I would still favor
one uniform federal rule against
marijuana but if there is not sufficient
consensus to obtain that then I think
the way to go is to permit a more
federal approach so States can you know
make their own decisions within the
framework of the federal law and so
we're not just ignoring the enforcement
of federal law now I haven't studied
specifically the state's law but I've
just circulated it through the
Department for comment I think that's
the process it's and now once we get
those comments you know we'll be able to
work with you on any concerns about the
state's law but I would much rather that
approach what the approach taken by the
the the states act then where we
currently are well I think you'll you'll
have a group of folks over here that
would like to work with you would like
to work with the Department on that let
me move to tavola and a special domestic
violence criminal jurisdiction in the in
the 2013 reauthorization of VAWA we
recognize tribal special domestic
violence criminal jurisdiction that
allowed tribes to prosecute non-native
domestic violence offenders in tribal
courts and this was for a limited class
of offenses so just last week the House
passed its reauthorization vehicle that
expands this jurisdiction to a broader
class of sexual assault and domestic
violence offenses as well as crimes
against children and assaults on tribal
police officers the the vehicle there
the reauthorization vehicle also allows
for a pilot project that is specific to
Alaska Native
that have 75% are graded native
population to exercise this jurisdiction
I think that all these provisions in the
House bill are step in the right
direction you and I have had discussion
about the issues of just protection in
general in outlying areas of very remote
parts of my state where we really have
have got to be thinking outside of the
box when it comes to how we provide for
protection and so allowing for these
these these limitations based on
jurisdiction are really really hard when
you have women and children that are
vulnerable so I am I'm hoping that we
can continue to work with you on these
jurisdictional issues I'm hopeful that
we'll have a chance to bring you up to
the state so we can get you out into
some of these villages see how these
tribal courts are functioning and and
again better explore the opportunities
to provide for a level of safety I do
appreciate you including the 5% tribal
set aside from the Crime Victims Fund I
think that this is going to make a
difference but if you have if you can
comment in any way on on this aspect of
of tribal jurisdiction and what it might
mean for domestic violence protection I
think I'll ask a Native women you know
face unacceptably high levels of
violence
I've actually scheduled a trip up to
Alaska specifically to visit some of
these communities and so I would
approach this with a little a great deal
of sympathy for the need to think
outside of the box and to do something
that's effective in protecting these
this vulnerable population and I'm
prepared to work with you to try to
fashion something that will work
appreciate that and also working on the
murdered missing and murdered missing
indigenous women's initiatives that
we're working on I look forward to that
as well too and welcoming into the state
thank you mr. chairman senator Manchin
thank you very much mr. chairman Thank
You mr. general
being here in your service I'm only
gonna say one thing about the model
report I would just compassionately ask
the more that you can reveal if it
doesn't interfere with the criminal
investigation or with intelligence that
we need to protect the more you can do
the more healing will happen for our
country I believe it would be very very
very helpful so I hope you would
consider that when you're when you're
releasing your report back to us the
other thing I wanted to say is on